what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I'm kind of excited because I'm
getting ready to go see Murder on the
Orient Express which is a movie I've
been looking forward to for a long time
ever since they announced a trailer for
it I loved the original and the book was
incredible the ending was a twist that I
never saw coming but I'm really hoping
this remake proves to be as successful
as the first one anyway
we are covering days of anger which is
basically Meister Hulk vs. old man Logan
and this is one of the coolest stories
now keep in mind up until this point
old man Logan's been written by a guy
named Jeff Lemire and it's been nothing
short of spectacular I mean it's one of
the greatest Wolverine runs ever done
but this story is written by Ed Britten
and this is really really good I'm
really excited to see what he does after
this but this also kind of offers a
weird situation this may be something
that that versland decides to follow up
with later on but at the moment we're
not given immediate answers what does
comic initially does is it basically
opens up with maestro Hulk in his Bruce
Banner form talking to a handful of
children about a better tomorrow about
all they have to do is basically
quote/unquote fix the world make the
world a place for the Hulk's to live
remember
maestro Hulk is a version of The
Incredible Hulk from an alternate
universe called future imperfect now the
original future imperfect was written
back in 1993 or something like that and
maestro Hulk made his appearances before
then but the whole idea of him is that
he is basically a version of the
Incredible Hulk
from a future where the world was
basically plummeted into absolute chaos
after a nuclear war and so there's only
real one location that humanity is able
to reside in and I believe is called
dystopia
but basically maestro hope rules it with
an iron fist now in the original future
imperfect story The Incredible Hulk from
the present day was yanked into the
future and then basically told we need
you to defeat the maestro initially Hulk
was like had his neck broken he was
totally overpowered ultimately it led to
the maestro being defeated quote-unquote
and then he made a few more appearances
on Marvel Comics whether in the
Incredible Hulk line or and things like
exiles when they were touring alternate
universes but it's one of these
scenarios where in Marvel Comics
whenever you read a story about a
dystopian future that is the absolute
future usually in event happens and then
that future changes and that future
becomes a what-if it becomes you know
some alternate reality where things took
place and that's how a lot of this stuff
works the problem with this is we're not
initially given immediate answers about
maestro and again we'll get into that as
we as we sort of continue on
we end up doing is actually picking up
in British Columbia with old man Logan
and stuff now remember during Jeff
lemierre's Ron and presumably going now
into Britain's run the whole idea of old
man Logan is that he was basically
thrown into the main Marvel Universe
after the events of Secret Wars and so
he's in a reality that's not his own and
the whole idea was him just kind of
coming to grips with everything that was
going on but this brings into sharp
relief him walking into a diner and
basically discovering that the people
who run the diner have been killed by
all the individuals who were here one of
whom is named Billy Bob and this is
extremely important because if you
recall the name Billy Bob that was the
name of one of the incredible Hawks from
the original old man Logan story and
that's when we find out not everybody in
the whole family was killed the original
old man Logan story was basically just a
future where the villains took over the
world and that was it they destroyed all
the superheroes they were led by Red
Skull they conquered everything wolf
rein was basically tricked into killing
all of the x-men and as a result had
essentially just retreated to a simple
farm life in this part of the country
that he lived in on the west coast
everything from like Washington State
all the way down to California was all
run by Bruce Banner The Incredible Hulk
in the old man Logan story it's
basically all these you know inbred kids
of Bruce Banner and Jennifer Walters
both of whom were just kind of driven
insane by all the radiation from you
know war that had broken out at the end
of the old man Logan story where old man
Logan had gone off on this quest with
the old version of Hawkeye in order to
try to see if they could basically
recreate Captain America only to find
out that it was a ruse when he came back
home The Hulk family had killed Logan's
family and so in response he went to
their trailer park and killed them all
including Bruce Banner what this story
reveals is that we're originally in that
story old man Logan had taken this
newborn baby Hulk basically and let
Billy Bob go that we ended up learning
there were other Hulk's that simply just
were not in that location at the time
but at the moment it's really just old
man Logan is stuck in a situation where
it's more questions and answers how did
they get here what in the world is going
on and that's the cool thing about this
is because on the surface it offers that
explanation it's basically this idea
where he's facing off against all these
Hawks they're throwing everything
including pots of grease and the whole
nine yards it offers this idea that
they're there for just basic revenge and
that's it
but when Billy Bob effectively takes off
and runs back to their base of
operations we end up finding out that
they're being led by maestro and so
again this is he
deal because something I hope you notice
here is maestro is a lot more intuitive
and a lot more intelligent than the
Incredible Hulk that were used to but
the first seeds of people who don't
necessarily view his intentions in the
same way he does comes with Cambria but
the problem is that billy-bob basically
threw away the element of surprise when
billy-bob retreated and took off running
what it did is it created a trail and
old man loved him with his enhanced
senses and so on and so forth can follow
that trail and that's the important
thing because that's the first thing
that maestro Hulk realizes as soon as
billy-bob shows up and says hey man
everybody out there they were killed by
you know this old guy with claws maestro
immediately realizes if he's anything
like the Wolverine that maestro is used
to from his own reality then an old man
Logan will find them and so what it does
is it immediately shrinks the timetable
and that's the important thing about
this because old man Logan does just
that he immediately begins to go on the
hunt of sorts and tries to track down
all these different versions of the Hulk
family and so what they end up doing is
basically saying okay we need to move to
a new location because we're previously
they were occupying a department age
facility which is part of the what the
next story that we haven't really dealt
with what they end up doing is actually
traveling to the Yukon Territory in
Canada under the auspices of taking over
another facility and operating from
there just because maestro has taken up
residence in a new location does not
mean that he's lowered his guard it does
not mean that he's resting on his
laurels instead it's going to be jumping
from one facility to the next or one
location to the next staying one step
ahead of old man Logan constantly
keeping him chasing after them and so
that's kind of an important thing here
because one of the other things that
maestro Hope basically says is they're
going to quote-unquote make the world a
better place they're going to eliminate
humanity he basically wants to make the
future imperfect world on the main
Marvel Universe which is to say he wants
to annihilate all of humanity and then
forced whoever's left to live under his
control it's basically a desire to
regain the power that he had during the
future imperfect story he just wants
power and that's it he's every villain
ever the other half of this is that we
actually pick up with old man Logan
reaching out to puck Park was originally
a teammate of the original Wolverine on
a group called alpha flight and alpha
flight was a Canadian special ops team
that was based out of Department K I
think it was and it was just one of
those weird things where it was just
kind of like okay Canada's superhero
team and pucks pretty cool but when all
new alder
Marvel kicked off because alpha flight
was kind of like this unsellable thing
in the sense that it does have fans but
it was never one of these high-profile
teams like Avengers what Marvel did is
they grabbed alpha flight and they
rolled it over into sword the sentient
world observation and the end response
department basically this sort of
spacefaring agency like shield in the
sense that shield monitors earth sword
monitors other other planets really
monitor space itself for any threat that
may impact the earth and so alpha
flights just operating under Captain
Marvel Carol Danvers and that's really
about it but this is important is
because with sword operating outside the
United States and outside the world well
they're not necessarily supposed to
monitor the u.s. itself
they really do I mean in a lot of ways
they have access to all the technology
that shield has access to you because
they're kind of sister organizations and
so because of that old man Logan calls
in a favor and says some nuclear weapons
left a Department age facility I need to
know where they're going or in the very
least where they are right now and so
again because of the fact that these are
nuclear weapons they have to have
location devices if for no other reason
than the idea that the person who
launches them has to know where they're
going and so with these these location
devices based on radio frequencies it's
nothing for you know puck to basically
tap into those radio locations and say
the nuclear weapons are here so again
this allows old man Logan to basically
continue the process of tracking down
the Hulk family now the cool thing about
this is that what we end up running into
is maestro essentially telling his guys
at least telling buck one of the members
of the old family two main things the
first is old man Logan will not stop
until he gets here
so you have two jobs to do the first is
to go out find old man Logan and keep
shooting until you're out of ammo the
second is to take Billy Bob with you and
kill him now this is pretty ruthless but
that's how maestro Hulk is this campaign
has followed out exactly the way that
maestro hawk specifies buck and all
these guys immediately target you know
old man Logan's start loading him full
of bullets the whole nine yards and
initially incapacitate him the problem
is that when they send Billy Bob out
there to issue the killing shot because
Billy Bob was the last person in the the
whole compound to be left alive in the
original old man Logan story his guns
full of blanks and the Hulk family
shoots him to death so again it's pretty
brutal but that's how things are now
under my stroke and so what this does is
this switches over to the oh man Logan
story with really this old Hawkeye and
old man Logan himself just kind of
hanging out this takes place in that
point in the story when Hawkeye showed
up on the door
first up of old man Logan and said hey
look I need you to help me with a
mission to basically revive the super
soldier program and so it's just one of
those little interim things not super
significant but with regards to old man
Logan himself in the here and now he's
more or less just been strung up and
he's just being used as target practice
he's just being used for the purpose of
the whole family getting their revenge
in truth if you read between the lines
maestro Hulk being as intelligent as he
is knows the only way for him to
maintain his campaign is to ensure the
people on him under him are happy and so
it's very much you know one of these uh
militaristic really like a governmental
campaign give the people just enough of
a reason to not complain and everything
will be fine if you push them to the
point where they feel like they have
nothing left then they'll attack all
they have to do is believe that what he
says is true and they'll do anything he
asked is very government like in that
capacity and so of course with old man
Logan being tormented he's not
unintelligent he's learned every trick
of the trade and talking to buck and
basically say you know poking fun at the
idea that old man Logan killed his whole
family basically saying hey look man you
know this reminds me you know if your of
your Hulk family man you know that kind
of thing you know I would've been
laughing about killing him if I wasn't
so busy killing them you know just
preying on that poking fun of him
basically saying you've lost everything
you care about and you're just as inept
as everybody else that I killed since
Hulk into a fury of sorts and in his
anger and in his rage he offers old man
Logan the escape by smashing the pillar
he's being strapped to an old man Logan
kills him following that it's an
absolute bloodbath I mean he takes on
every last one of these members of the
Hulk family and the last one who's left
alive spills the beans on everything and
so transitioning over to maestro when we
end up having Malachi basically one of
the kids here go to maestro and say hey
look Cambria took off she doesn't seem
to be you know aligned with your
viewpoints different things like that
maestro says okay we'll track her down
later but we've got bigger fish to fry
it's basically splitting the difference
and again that's the military tactical
nature of Maestro when he sits down and
he says we have a choice we're at a
crossroads either we can carry out my
campaign or we can go after Cambria at
the end of the day it's carry out my
campaign oh man Logan's gonna catch us
eventually so the sooner we carry this
out the sooner we can deal with him and
the sooner I get the world that I want
so what we end up doing is jumping back
to old man Logan himself hiding out and
trying to get his bearings and he's met
by the arrival of the modern-day Hawkeye
now again this is cool this is one of
the reasons
why old man Logan is so intriguing
because at this moment right now he's
stuck at an impassive source in the
sense that he's trying to figure out how
to handle the character of Hawkeye but
Before we jump into that we kind of
jumped back to this you know flashback
that old man Logan has again when he's
spending time with the old version of
Hawkeye and the original old man Logan's
story and we end up finding out the
Cambria is a person they've already met
before the Cambria was basically someone
who defected from Bruce banners family
she didn't like the idea of being part
of their whole group but she was
basically stealing pigs from old man
Logan's farm in order to keep her
appetite satiated and so on and so forth
old man Logan let her take one but said
look you can't keep doing this the
response of old Hawkeye wish to shoot
her but because of the fact that old man
Logan's spared her life this comes back
to roost in the here and now
because what is up happening is picking
up with Hawkeye himself and with old man
Logan it's kind of cool because old man
Logan basically says look you know and
it's already been established in old man
Logan's universe
Hawkeye dies I mean he basically gets
shot in the head and even old man Logan
goes as far as to say this when Hawkeye
says hey what am I like in your future
you know in your timeline am i cool and
my awesome old man Logan says actually
no you're not you marry you marry
spider-man's daughter uh you end up
getting cataracts you go blind and you
get shot in the head and die it's a
pretty miserable life it's not the
glorious of futures you know for Hawkeye
so it's kind of funny the issue with
this is that this is how things started
when it came to old man Logan and the
old Hawkeye in the old man Logan story
Hawkeye just showed up on his doorstep
old blind said hey look I need your help
and they went on a road trip the last
time this happened Hawkeye was shot in
the head that's what oh man Logan is
afraid of repeating itself the
circumstances might be different but the
idea is that it will end in Hawkeye
dying and that's what he's afraid of
this cycle repeating itself and him
being unable to save a friend and so
that's what we end up learning the whole
basis behind what it is that maestro
Hulk wants to do is basically grab his
Hulk family and send each one of them to
a major metropolitan city and blow it up
using a nuke city humanity is scattering
to the winds that's the goal here
annihilate major cities because when
that happens humanity will do the only
thing it knows how to do it'll flee to
petty warlords
it'll flee to anybody who can offer a
measure of protection and that's what
he's shooting for take those who were
too weak to protect themselves who can't
survive the harsh environment of a
lawless world bring them under his rule
and crown himself as a warlord the other
half of this is the
of Cambria herself because of the fact
that she was the girl that oh man Logan
had saved in his own universe when she
defects she immediately heads to him
because her hope is that he'll recognize
her which he does and that's what he
tells Hawkeye stand down
she's on our side if she says she's on
our side so again there's a little bit
of camaraderie here not only that
because of the fact that all these
versions of the Hulk family starts
showing up in all these major cities the
crisis is immediately diverted and the
reason for this is because they were
basically
fail-safes installing each and every one
of these nuclear weapons that if a
person used them without the right
access codes did they would ultimately
just kind of fail now in truth it was
really the only way to wrap this story
up right I mean a lot of people may say
man it's just kind of like a throwaway
think it was the only way to wrap it up
unless we're talking about actually
detonating bombs throughout all the
major cities in the Marvel Universe in
which case good luck getting everybody
else to fall in line with that
continuity so comic logic is par for the
course what we end up getting instead of
this massive you know global apocalypse
is maestro Hulk fighting old man Logan
and it's super cool because this is a
ruthless battle between the two almost
immediately after the skirmish starts
Malachi basically picks up one of the
nuclear bombs and says hey look if you
do not stop I'm gonna blow us both up
but Malachi's basically talked down by
the combined efforts of Cambria oh man
Logan and Hawkeye and that kind of a
thing but when my show comes back to and
tries to detonate this bomb and has
ultimately stopped him and old man Logan
immediately jump into it and it's a cool
thing now in truth if this was 1993 and
this was a story that was being told no
way old man Logan would stand a chance
not happening but it is cool to see this
happen because you know old man Logan
doesn't know who maestro Hope is so
maestro Hulk doesn't really know who old
man Logan is he just views him as a
version of Wolverine from a different
universe that was thrown into the main
Marvel Universe and that was about it
and even with the backstory we're not
given any information of how maestro
Hulk arrived in the old man Logan story
he was in the contest of Champions story
but that story ended with him in a giant
cell so I mean it's not like one leads
to the others we have no way to connect
the dots but my show Hulk isn't
necessarily a guy who you know while he
is looking for the future and perfect
thing it's not absolute power and
absolute conquering that he's shooting
for it in his mind because of the fact
that Bruce Banner was killed in this
universe during the events of civil war
- then is basically him saying it's only
a matter of time before they seek us out
and it's only a matter of time before
they kill us
when that time comes either we can be
ahead of the ball you know we can we can
be ahead of the game or we can be stuck
behind the 8-ball but the whole idea of
old man Logan is he's trying to find
solace in this universe he's trying to
find a life worth living
that'll be disrupted all the pieces when
the original will rain comes back and
I'm really excited to see when those two
characters meet imagine that old man
Logan meets Wolverine meets classic will
ring that'll be a that'll be a story for
the ages I would hope anyway but this
really kind of winds down fast because
what it does is Edwardson grabs the
character of Maestro and says he's going
to return he's gonna come back we've
really kind of plays into the character
of maestro maestro says look run run run
away live to fight another day and so he
ends up just backing off he ends up just
walking away and saying look you're you
are a lot more kibble than I thought you
were but my schemes are never done I
will return any effectively just leaves
now some people kind of consider that to
be somewhat of a weak ending but I don't
I mean I look at it as basically Britten
saying my stroke will come back in some
form or fashion maybe he'll come back in
the old man Logan story maybe he'll come
back in a different story but regardless
we'll see him again and that's kind of
what I'm looking you know what I'm
looking forward to in this is because
it's the idea of him returning but
things wrap up pretty straightforward I
mean that's it you know it's hawkeye old
man Logan basically talking about the
nature of Maestro Hulk what old man
Logan learned effectively everything
that I just told you about feature and
perfect and it's them just kind of
continuing their friendship and that's
really about it they just kind of wrap
up pretty quick but it's a cool story
it's a cool concept maestro's always
been one of my favorite versions of The
Incredible Hulk
having him encounter old man Logan
continues this idea that there are still
characters out there after the events of
secret Wars that can still be rolled
over into the main model universe and
still give us some pretty darn good
storytelling but with that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]